I'm not gonna worry about I'm not going
to speculate on anything until I have to
address that someone tell that we're
gonna stay in the now we're going to
stay in the focus on what we what we're
doing right now so again as far as I'm
concerned we're just not going to deal
with the question until it's time and
when it the time comes and then I'll you
know I will address it but until as far
as I'm concerned he's in his rehab
program he's doing his program our
quarterback right now has been playing
for us this Kyle so we're not gonna
address it that is Ron Rivera the
Panthers coach and he's been irritated
from time to time regarding questions
about Cam Newton and now that Cam Newton
is inching closer and closer to health
he's gonna be asked those questions far
more often Chris reportedly according to
ESPN Cam Newton already returned to
practice after the upcoming bye week and
once he's healthy there's gonna be a
tough decision for the Panthers to make
Kyle Allen is four and oh and look when
both guys are healthy there's no
question Cam Newton is the better
quarterback but the question becomes and
we went through this with Nick Falls and
Carson Wentz in the past one guys the
better quarterback but you could argue
with it with the other guy you got a
better team yeah how do you see this
playing out yeah I mean this is really
this is intriguing I you know I don't
know how it's gonna play I'll say this
you know and I have a I'm of great
respect for Cam Newton I think he's the
man I mean I really do but in this
scenario I would keep riding the hot
hand of Kyle Allen I don't care if Cam
Newton comes out next week in practice
and he looks great
and he could be throwing you know
missiles all over the field and I still
would go with Kyle Allen they have a
formula that works right now and I
really would not avoid it or get away
from it until you know we see some some
you know cracks in the armor and see
where it goes from there from that point
but he's taking care of the football
he's really playing the position just
pure it's not like wow moments you don't
go oh my gosh but they don't need it
they can run the ball they have weapons
North Turner's creative to find other
ways to make stuff happen and then we
know their defense is very special I
would have a hard time I certainly
wouldn't do it right now
I would ride with Kyle Allen and and
wait to see maybe if he falters and then
you know you got an ace in the hole
there with Cam Newton off the bench
here's the other problem
- how do you trust that Cam Newton
really does feel fun because he
essentially lied to the team week 1 and
week 2 now he should have known that
there was something wrong with him but
is he potentially pushing himself a
little harder than he should because he
sees what Kyle Allen is doing and I
think it's human nature right if you're
drew brees you see teddy bridgewater
you're working at exercises or now he's
working that thing the wazoo with the
thumb exercise right but but with Kyle
with Cam Newton same same dynamic yeah
this guy is taking my job and he's
running with my job and I better get my
butt back on the field or there may not
be a job for me when I am ready to go
and you know we talked yesterday about
what the future holds for Cam Newton we
did that in PFT Ooty and look III don't
know where this goes from here but I
keep coming back to something Chris that
we you and I have discussed multiple
times the idea that when Cam Newton is
healthy when he truly is healthy you
just put him on the field and you quit
worrying about him getting injured
because if he does he got Kyle Allen so
you no longer have to tiptoe around it
look look Cam Newton do all the things
that make Cam Newton the MVP in 2015 and
if he does get injured put Kyle Allen
back in and the offense continues to
roll like it has in Cam Newton's apps so
you you would you think you'd go there
you'd go there when he's healthy yeah
when he's healthy but I don't know when
he's doing a series yeah you'd have to
put him through a series of tests run
wind sprints you know you'd want to see
it all you know run through how exactly
I hear you I want I don't want to just
take his word for it hey are you okay
yeah I'm okay all right go play no I
want to see that you can do everything
you need to do on that foot before I put
you back on the field and disrupt the
vibe that we've created without you yeah
once you truly are 100% ready to go and
and I would say to him Kim take your
time right take your time if you could
come back a hundred percent for the
playoff run think about how much better
we'll be right even if you don't come
back 100% until the first round of the
playoffs we're so much better with you
if you're healthy but you got to get
healthy and I think that's how you
manage it if you're paying you at least
try to manage it that way if you're the
Panthers the problem is with each
passing week Cam Newton is getting more
and more antsy about the fact that the
ship is sailing away without him yeah
sure well hey these are legacy defining
moments I mean that's you know there's
like you said drew brees it's he he
doesn't like it Cam Newton doesn't like
it I get it I just think with the NSC
the way it's playing out right now and
as competitive as it is I would I would
be scared of you know losing a game or
maybe two for Cam Newton you know to
kind of get back in the rhythm even if
he is a hundred percent healthy I don't
care if you're Superman Brady Rogers
Peyton Manning when you haven't played
football in a long time you're not just
gonna go out there and throw strikes all
over the field and that's what I would
worry about so I would really take my
time and let just let's ride this out
the Panthers are hot and Kyle Allen's
hot and let's not mess that up
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports